McVeigh need erector of the Office of
Management and Budget joins us from the
White House he's responsible for taking
the steps necessary to implement the
government shutdown director Mulvaney
good morning good morning thanks very
much for having me I want to get to the
particular zuv whether they'll be a deal
but first this the death benefits to the
families of military members killed in
action will not be paid during this
shutdown is the White House pushing
Congress to act on this absolutely for
that reason and a myriad of other
reasons I think that everyone admits and
acknowledges the president did not want
this shutdown actively worked to prevent
the shutdown the stories that you've
heard about the death benefits to the to
service members who were killed there
are absolutely true there are other
stories like that throughout the
government the government should be open
we should not however be negotiating
over a non-financial issue the daca
issue as part of keeping the government
open those discussions on daca were
going on before the shutdown they'll go
on after the shutdown but they should
not be tied to the funding bill for the
government mix Senator McCaskill
introduced legislation to withhold paint
from members of Congress while the
government is shutdown should that
happen sure when I was in Congress I was
in Congress for the shutdown of 2013 we
had a basic rule which said that we
would get paid the same way that our
staff would get paid so if staff didn't
get paid Congress wouldn't get paid if
staff got paid late Congress get paid
late I think that's just good practice
we'll be doing the same thing here at
the Office of Management budget well you
have experienced director Mulvaney with
a shutdown you voted for it over the
issue of Obamacare back in 2013 and now
the Democrats are holding it up for
docket for daca why was it okay back in
2013 and not okay now I keep on when you
say vote for a shutdown what you do is
you vote for or against a funding bill
and in 2013 conservative Republicans
like myself were asked to vote for a
funding bill that included full funding
for Obamacare something to which we
objected and for that reason we refused
to vote for this bill is different this
fact this is something the likes of
which Washington has never seen before
this is a bill that Democrats support
yet they are still not voting for it
they oppose the bill but they don't
really oppose the parts of it they
support keeping the government open they
support the children's health insurance
program they support the delay in the
various taxes including
the Cadillac tax within Obamacare it's
the first time I think anybody can
remember seeing this in Washington maybe
it speaks to how bad the dysfunction is
within the Senate Democrats mix talk
about dysfunction for just a second do
you think the president should be doing
Maury he prides himself on being a deal
maker I'm hard-pressed to know what else
the president could do he met last week
with large groups of members of both
parties he's continued to work the
phones I think you know that mr. Schumer
was here by himself I think for more
than an hour and a half on Friday it's
hard to imagine the president being more
engaged and I do compared to President
Obama's lack of engagement in 2013
wasn't back then I think was encouraging
this shutdown this president is working
very hard to make sure it didn't happen
the first place now that his here he's
working hard to make sure it stops who
you think has to get in a room together
to figure this out you mentioned the
meeting on Friday between Chuck Schumer
and the president that didn't work who
has to be in a room in your estimation
this morning yeah I think the folks who
hold the cards here are the Democrats
who say they want to work across the
aisle the ones who go home John tester
who goes back to Montana and says you
know I'm vote for me I'm a really good
bipartisan guy I can work for
Republicans folks like that who are now
here in Washington not doing that those
are the folks who hold the keys the
folks who say one thing back home and do
another here that's what we need Chuck
Schumer clearly he's heavily invested in
this shutdown he's a leader of the
Democrat Party we get that but there are
rank-and-file democrats who have said
they want to work across the aisle now
is their chance to do that make how long
does this last for I don't know I sort
of thought it would be done by this
morning simply because I thought that
part of this was an attempt by some of
the Democrat leadership most
specifically mr. Schumer to deny the
president sort of this week weekend the
worth of media talking about the
one-year anniversary of the inauguration
I wouldn't be surprised if it reopens
today at the vote in noon but if it
doesn't it could go for several days did
you talk to the president this weekend
was that was he upset that he did not
make it tomorrow logo for the
celebration of his 1 year in office I
think the president was upset that the
government was closed and the government
we were talking about this on media
instead of talking about the tax plan
and how many jobs he's created in the
stock market how we've defeated Isis how
the two koreas are talking to each other
there's a long list of successes in the
first year that didn't get any attention
this weekend because of the shutdown all
right Mick Mulvaney thank you very much
thanks y'all